pocas horas de nochebuena muchos buscan
a paz mental en europa con larguísimas
colas delante de farmacias para
conseguir un test de antígenos en lisboa
la población quiere asegurarse un
negativo en kobe 19 antes de reunirse
con sus familias mientras portugal
registra la cifra más alta de contagios
desde enero
decidí hacerme la prueba para estar con
la familia durante la navidad ya que hay
personas mayores en la familia fue para
asegurarme de que el virus no se
transmite a otros miembros de la familia
para transmitir pues productos transfer
miliar una situación similar a la de
españa donde la variante o micro dónde
el coronavirus está arrasando allí los
kits de pruebas a domicilio se han
agotado en la mayoría de las farmacias
del país y ante este repunte de casos el
gobierno ha vuelto a imponer la
obligatoriedad de mascarillas en
exteriores puedes hacerme una prueba de
antígenos de cara a estos días por qué
un familiar un nieto exactamente una
neta que no tiene nada positivo y bueno
de cara a juntarnos no todos los que
queríamos pero bueno algunos y podemos
en francia también los parisinos
intentaron obtener resultados en el
último momento antes de reunirse con sus
seres queridos el gobierno ha advertido
que se están produciendo más contagios
que nunca en el territorio razón por la
que el ejecutivo de macrón ha cancelado
las reuniones de año nuevo
no tengo mucha opción mi hermano dio
positivo ayer y vivo con él así que
obviamente las navidades no serán
similares a las pasadas ya que estaremos
en un grupo pequeño y será aún más
pequeño si acabamos dando positivo que
nunca por esto aunque en medio de tanta
preocupación también hubo lugar para
problemas más cotidianos como las
compras navideñas de última hora para
los más rezagados